dear president zielinski distinguished
guests people of Ukraine
when Brave ukrainians fiercely stopped
The Invader from advancing on Keith
they exposed a heinous truth
in butcher
Russian soldiers had looted and burned
homes tortured raped and murdered
innocent civilians
I was in butcher after its liberation
the barbarity of the attacks was
palpable
the site of mass Graves and body bags
lined up on the ground is etched forever
in my memory
and so are the people behind the
horrific Stories the young men with
their hands tied behind their backs shot
in the head
the grandfather who was shot in the back
while riding his bicycle
not even women and children were spared
one year on it is clear
what happened in butcher was not a
random episode
those executions in Cold Blood were part
of a bigger plan
cruel
cynical calculated
Kremlin wants to eliminate Ukraine its
statehood its independence and democracy
and the Kremlin wants to eliminate
ukrainians their national identity their
sense of being the history and the hope
and the future
these are war crimes
these are crimes against humanity
and the butcher massacres have been
replicated in other Ukrainian lands
occupied by Russian forces
another Target in Putin's plan is
children
Ukraine says over 16
200 children have been abducted
they have been deported to Russia
removed from their families and
communities
deprived of their childhood and their
roots
this is yet another blatant attempt at
erasing the Ukrainian identity
it is undeniable
it is Unforgivable
and it is punishable
and so for the first time in history
the international criminal court has
issued an arrest warrant
for a leader of a permanent member of
the U.N security Council
by charging Putin the prosecutor of the
international criminal court has sent a
clear message
there will be no Escape for the
perpetrator and his henchmen
war criminals will be held accountable
for their deeds
the European Union is working on the
collection of evidence and bringing
prosecutors together
we have also recently set up an
international coordination center for
the prosecution of the crime of
aggression
this is done as part of the joint
investigation team in eurojust
and in which the ICC also participates
and we will continue to spearhead
efforts to make sure
that Putin can be held accountable for
the crime of aggression
to that end we continue to support the
creation of a dedicated tribunal if
that's what it takes
this is for Ukraine
and for every country's right to exist
to be free and to write its own future
not only do we want Russia's criminal
plan to fail we want Justice for Ukraine
and for ukrainians Slava Ukraine